welcome to Udacity z-- ask a career
coach my name is Martin McGovern and we
are just going to take a couple of
minutes right now to allow people to
filter in join the live chat so if you
are here please post your location and
what you're working on right now what
your job title is or dream job title is
in the chat
we've got Rui there she's gonna be
collecting questions throughout the
conversation today and we're going to be
answering all of your questions or at
least as many as we can in the next hour
so bear a hold-hold with me as we give a
few minutes for folks to join the
webinar and we will jump on in thank you
so much for joining today's ask a career
coach on YouTube live I'm excited to get
into it all right we got people coming
in we got San Francisco San Jose we've
got India currently ending the data
science nanodegree welcome Washington DC
San Francisco that's us I'm actually in
Chicago so if there's any Chicagoans out
there we got a nice like chilly day out
here today we got India it's 1:30 in the
morning in India oh my goodness thank
you so much for staying up or waking up
and joining us
that is some serious dedication super
happy to have you here all right we got
some
coming in Thank You Hagee we're gonna be
collecting these questions and going
through them throughout the presentation
here the one that we're gonna kick off
with is around behavioral interviews we
posted a video today with the Udacity
app Udacity career tips we talked about
the behavioral interview and the three
questions you can likely get so we're
gonna kick off this conversation in
about three minutes talking about that
so any questions you have around
behavioral interviews or interviews in
general please put them in the chat and
that will be the main part of the
discussion or at least the initial part
of our discussion today Before we jump
into all the topics that are on your
minds right it's foggy on the bridge
maybe that maybe maybe you're in
Chicago too yeah I could see some fog
out there beautiful Seattle dream job
would be a product manager awesome
machine learning
all right we got some questions about
experience Pedro your question if you
could provide a little bit more context
around what you mean by no experience
have you ever worked any jobs
internships anything all the way back to
you know my first job was mowing lawn
when I was in a teenager put a little
more context in and we'll definitely get
to your question all right Thank You
Hagee these are great questions keep
them coming and we're just going to hold
and wait for a few more folks to join
the chat
[Music]
right Daniel thank you for sharing your
question keep the questions coming
everyone
is going to be exciting we got a lot of
stuff to talk about today
start getting into it now we're about
five minutes into the call for those of
you who are just joining please put your
name your location and your career
question in the chat Ruiz going to be
collecting our questions throughout the
presentation today or at least
throughout the conversation today and we
will be diving in our main topic is
around behavioral interviews but feel
free to ask questions about anything
related to the job search and what
you're currently working on really
excited to jump in thank you again for
joining us today from all over the
country all over the world it's gonna be
a good combo all right so the first
thing that we want to chat about today
we posted a video in the Udacity career
tips video series I believe it's videos
sixteen and in that video we talked
about the behavioral interview and the
number one thing that I see happening in
a behavioral interview is that people
tend to be very vague with their answers
we wish we could just say I need a job I
need to pay rent please hire me like
that would be that would be the thing we
wish we could say because it is honest
but it's a little too honest and it's
actually not really what you're there
for what you're there for isn't for them
to give you money although that's part
of the transaction while you're there
for is to provide value what you do what
your skill set is solves problems for an
employer so when you're talking to them
during an interview situation if you're
not addressing how you solve problems
you're completely missing the mark as to
what they're trying to figure out about
you so for instance a lot of people will
get questions around you know what's the
time that you struggle to the co worker
what are your strengths and weaknesses
tell me about yourself and we give very
general answers that never tie back to
the role that you're trying to get that
never tie back to the thing you're
trying to do the problem you're trying
to solve so what you want to do when
you're thinking about answering
questions during a behavioral interview
is always tie it to specific examples to
specific examples of what you've done in
the past
and what you can do in the future so for
instance what's a time that you've
struggled with a co-worker most people
say well this one time I was working on
a project they don't specify what the
project is they don't specify what the
goals of the project were they don't
even specify what the problem was that
came up that the project was built in to
solve and so then the person who's
listening to you never gets a really
clear sense of what you're working on
just this general abstract idea of a
project and then they go on to say and I
you know I had a co-worker who I you
know didn't quite see eye to eye with
now you never said the person's name you
never said anything about them it's like
watching a movie and never getting to
see the character on screen how are you
ever going to relate to the story if you
can't put an image in your head so you
need to give a name or you need to give
some sort of descriptor of the person
maybe you know the developer or whatever
the thing is that you want to use to
describe that person then you need to
explain what the goal is that you are
trying to get to and why this
interaction that was a struggle was
hindering your progress toward that goal
so I was you know we started we kicked
off this project we're working towards
it and then Sally Sally Joe you know she
and I just couldn't see eye-to-eye
something happened right and you
specifically detail out the issue that
happened a example not just we struggled
because again I can't picture that you
need to actually say what you struggled
with so you and Sally are struggling
right but you have to figure it out you
have to come to some sort of conclusion
maybe you tried a couple things set up a
one-on-one did some different things did
it work did it not work what were the
solutions that you attempted to
implement
in order to continue working towards
this goal that you and Sally both have
together and then you need to explain
the outcome this is the hero's journey
rising action conflict climax and
resolution you need to bring it back to
a resolution the resolution is that the
project continued to move forward and
had good results and what you can say is
I learned how to
interpersonal you know conflict and
conversations and still stay on target
which is something that I can do in
future projects when I'm working with
your team boom now you've got a story
arc that ties back to what you're here
to talk about which is this job and the
same goes with strengths and weaknesses
and tell me about yourself just talking
about myself if I said you know I really
love to go to the movies what does that
have to do with my job what does that
have to do with the problems that I
solve for my employer sure I'm really
into Marvel movies but what does that
matter to them right we need to be
talking about things that matter to the
employer and you have to realize at the
end of the day when you're in a
behavioral interview it's not really
about you it's about how you can help
them with the problems that they have in
their company so it's a definite shift
in mindset let's say you're a front-end
developer right maybe user experience or
beautiful design or whatever the thing
is that you value most about your work
saying I can bring that in and revé an
you know refresh the website or create a
simpler experience that enables people
to purchase more you can create these
ties from the work you do to the
problems and needs that they have in the
business and the baseline business goals
so there's a lot of things that we can
do in a behavioral interview but the
main thing you want to do is give
specific examples and then tie it to the
problem at hand that you can help solve
so as we go into this idea this this
discussion about about the behavioral
interview we've already got a few
questions coming in about additional
things that we'd like to dive into so
please if you have any other behavioral
interview questions put them in the chat
and ruie we'll be sending them my way so
we can get into it all today super
excited to jump in and again if you have
any other career questions please add
them as well
[Music]
alright alright our first question we've
gotten a number of questions from Hagee
thank you so much huggy for joining us
again this week your first question is
how can I show my passion during an
interview this is a really interesting
question because it starts much further
before the interview if you wait until
you're in an interview and you realize
you're at a company that you don't
really care about it's gonna be hard to
fake your interest and I know passion is
a very overused word right now but the
key thing here is interest interest not
only in the topic at hand but in the
problems that need to be solved in order
to move that industry forward so let's
say you know you're searching for a job
you don't know what you want to do you
have an idea of the job title and you're
just applying to everything one day you
have an interview with a shoe company
the next day you have an interview with
a bread company and the day after that
you have an interview with someone who's
I don't know selling other widgets how
are you going to be in your head
passionate about all those things you're
probably not you know if you are talking
to a credit card company and you have
zero interest in credit cards or
knowledge of the credit card industry
it's gonna be a tougher conversation
than if you are obsessed with video
games and you're talking to a video game
developer so yeah I would say the first
thing you need to do in order to show
your passion during an interview is get
interviews at companies that you have an
interest in the way you do that is you
write down your favorite hobbies I know
a lot of people I talked to it's usually
something in the recreation space I like
to hike I like to canoe I like to cook
so the cooking space is a big one I'm
really into reading audiobooks and the
publishing industry I'm really into
education and the education industry
finance and the financial industry
there's all sorts of industries and you
can look on LinkedIn for all the
different types of industry codes so
when you're doing your job search I
would focus on let's say the top five
industries that you're most interested
in so that we
get to the interview you don't have to
do anything other than be interested the
way that you already are so if someone
were to ask me a question about
education I clearly could talk for a
long time about it but if someone were
to ask me a question about sports oh man
that'd be a really rough one if I ever
get a at an interview at I don't know
this Sox here in Chicago for a marketing
position
they'd be like well what are your
thoughts about marketing in the sports
industry and I would just be you know it
would be a lot of faking it right it
would be a lot of uh yeah no I totally
went to Sox games as a kid and that was
interesting I don't know anything about
baseball so it's going to be really hard
to show my passion however if I'm
chatting with a company that's you know
working on changing education like
Udacity that is going to be a
conversation that I can have for hours
and the passion isn't something I have
to show it's something that's just going
to come through so take a look at your
interests what do you like to read about
what do you like to browse online maybe
social media is your passion and you're
obsessed with culture and Instagram you
know what is the future of that in the
role and what role can you play in
making that future better that's how you
need to think about it if you can tie
your skill set to the problems in that
industry that you're interested in and
talk about the long term success and
development of that industry you're
gonna be on the right path to really
showcasing your passion and alright our
second question I'm going to jump to
Nathaniel can you give some advice on
how to find out who the hiring manager
is for a certain position for the
purpose of following up on an
application I've heard advice such as
such as searching LinkedIn for people at
the company asking connections that work
there to look it up or even calling the
front desk to ask I've tried all those
techniques and they rarely work
especially for large companies this is a
great question Nathaniel so there's a
lot of different there there's a lot
going on when it comes to
how to get to the decision-maker and I
definitely think it's important to get
closer and closer and closer to the
decision-maker that's just basic sales
the worst thing to do would be the worst
thing to do would be to only apply via
job boards on LinkedIn indeed and things
like that because you have the job board
the filter through the job board any
sort of resume screens that they have
any sort of reviewer screen that they
have then a manager screen a hiring
manager screen and so on there's
potentially you know six or seven layers
between you and the person that makes a
decision this is a far cry from when my
grandpa first came to the United States
grabbed a bag of tools went up to a
construction site and said do you need
help building this wall that's direct to
the person that can give him the job
right
he went to maybe four or five different
construction sites got the job
eventually became foreman and the rest
is history
but in our digital world with all these
promises from these websites saying
we're gonna get you the job and then of
course they never deliver to the degree
that we wish they would there's a number
of different things that you can try to
do one thing in particular is that
LinkedIn does sometimes have like who
the hiring manager is in the listing
maybe that's a premium feature it might
be a general feature I'm not entirely
sure but I've seen that now the issue is
if you apply and then you reach out to
them there might be a lot of people
reaching out to them but there might not
so it probably wouldn't hurt to reach
out to that person who they list as the
contact for that role the other thing to
do is getting to the hiring manager
while that's important we don't always
know who the hiring manager is so you
can spend lots and lots of time trying
to navigate in like a salesman but the
thing is none of us are salespeople
where developers coders marketers things
like that now it's a good skill set to
have and if you want to build it 100% go
for it but there's other things that you
can do too just getting a referral from
someone within the company typically
puts you high on the list for
consideration by the eventual hiring
manager
so you might not need to get to the
number one decision maker that might
come after they review your application
and invite you in for an interview but
what you can do is just reach out to
four or five people who work in the job
title that you wish you had at that
company and talk to them see what their
team is like see what it's like to work
there and then say hey are you uh if
there's ever an opportunity where your
team is growing would you mind passing
along my resume and then they can pass
you along and so what you do is you
create Alert on LinkedIn when roles pop
up you reach back out and you've already
had conversations before so it's much
easier to get through the door just to
go through some of the ones that you've
brought up here I've heard I've heard
advice such as searching LinkedIn for
people at the company all right so
that's the one that I that I just
recommended and you said that these
things aren't quite working my question
would be what types of messages are you
sending out is your first message that
you've sent out hey I'm looking for a
job does and and just go look up the
last five messages you sent did they
start with the word I or my a lot of
times the first message we ever send a
stranger is hi my name is Martin I want
this job can you give it to me and the
problem with that is that they don't
know who you are so they're gonna say I
don't care I don't know who you are no I
can't help you right so we need to build
rapport with people before we ask
there's actually a book out there called
I think it's a jab jab right hook or
something like that and it's about
giving before you get and so if you
haven't had any conversations with
people and you're just immediately going
into saying give me a job I'm sure a lot
of us are out there doing it and not
getting very good results so take a look
audit the messages you're sending out
and see where you can make it more about
them and less about you more about
trying to learn and ask advice rather
than asking for them to do something for
you because honestly we we haven't
always earned the right for someone to
do something for us a lot of people will
do it out of the you know kindness
their own heart but it's much easier to
get someone on the phone and talk to
them and then ask them for a referral
than to get a referral without any sort
of rapport conversation another one you
have listed here is calling the front
desk to ask yeah that's a hard one it's
it's a tough one cuz a lot of people
work remote these days and however I
will say there was someone who applied
for a job once and they came into the
office and I am not in the in California
so that I of course couldn't meet with
them but I personally liked the
initiative so I did have a call with
them it didn't but not being a fit but
it was you know it got them to the
interview I don't necessarily recommend
that as your baseline strategy and
calling the front desk probably won't
get you to where you need to be because
most people use slack and email nowadays
and they don't like to be on the phone I
would say it's probably better to reach
out to people directly and try and set
up coffees or Skype calls rather than
get in through the front desk but hey
there are a million different strategies
that work it's just about your execution
that's really what we need to focus on
any of these things could work if
executed correctly and the way that you
execute is you make it more about them
than about you I mean we've had those
things where someone pretended they were
delivering doughnuts to an office and in
the donut box was a bunch of resumes or
something like that and doughnuts
don't don't skimp on the doughnuts
that'll make people mad but they got
them in the door they said I have
doughnuts for this person they walk
straight into the CEOs office I I
believe that was the story that I heard
and then I think I touched on all I'm
asking connections yeah all right so I
think I touch on all the questions at
that one Nathaniel thank you so much for
your question and let me know if there's
any add-ons to that or any other
questions you have we'll try and get to
them today
[Music]
okay our next question how should you
answer the question or not really a
question but the statement tell me about
yourself we've actually had two people
ask this question I believe so thank you
so much for the question
tell me about yourself this is the most
broad question and it's how I start
every single one of my career calls just
to listen to people ramble and rant and
twist themselves into a pretzel trying
to come up with an answer I'm not gonna
lie I sometimes even struggle with it
when I'm caught off guard when you're
trying to answer the question of tell me
about yourself
you have to realize what they're
actually asking they're not asking tell
me who you are in your soul or tell me
everything about you from your education
to today they're asking why are we
talking why are you and I chatting today
like what are we doing here what's the
purpose of this conversation now of
course this can be interpreted a million
different ways and everyone might have
their own interpretation in their head
of what they want to hear but if you try
and think about it from the perspective
of they would like to know what is going
to be the purpose of this conversation
what is going to be the direction of
this conversation this will almost
always be the first question you're
asked so you get to set the direction
and the tone they're basically looking
at you and saying set us on course so
when you answer this question probably
the best thing to do is lead with
something along the lines of my name is
and and this is actually how I used to
break it down when I would do personal
brand coaching the if you've ever heard
of the why how what method this is why I
do it I do it's by simon Sinek this is
why I do what I do this is how I do what
I do and this is what it looks like for
you so personally I want to reduce
people's anxiety and help them get jobs
I do this through coaching content and
all sorts of other marketing and
coaching tactics and so I do that
through coaching and then how I do it is
through marketing campaigns YouTube
lives any other sort of one-on-ones
things like that so when you break it
down it's you know this is what I
believe in this is how I execute that
belief and this is how how you see it so
I'm sorry I'm rambling a little bit
which we all do when we're asked this
question but the idea here is you want
to keep it concise say you know I'm I'm
a developer I I'm really someone who
believes in a beautiful design so I
learned front-end programming in order
to help companies develop websites that
people want to land on there you go
I'm a programmer who's really interested
in design I create websites for
companies that want to have a beautiful
place for people to land on and interact
with their brand that is one way to
answer that question if that's what
makes sense to you or you could say I
believe in efficiency and I'm a
programmer who's really focused on
efficiency and so I create websites that
are not clunky that are streamlined that
it's very easy to find what you need and
I do that through my organizational
skills so I'm really excited to chat
with you today about the things that are
going on at your company and how I can
help organize your information so that
you have the best customer experience
I'm just kind of spitballing a few ideas
of how these answers could look for you
so that you can figure out how to make
it work for yourself and if you want to
you know give it a shot maybe write your
little pitch your why how what in the
comments please do and and we can
critique it together and possibly even
share it later in future videos or on
LinkedIn or slack or somewhere
all right I'm going to jump to Ryan's
question here how do you approach the
question why is your current job not a
development job related to the position
you are applying to I really appreciate
this question Ryan I wish I had a little
bit more information of what industry
you're coming from but the key thing
here is to remember that your past
experience always informs your future
work so for instance I was working with
someone recently whose background is in
mental health and therapy and things
like that and so they've moved into
programming and what the commonality
between the two parts of their lives
their career work life the commonality
between the two sides of their work
lives is that back when they were doing
therapy they worked really hard with
people in order to change behavior so
just getting someone to get up out of
bed in the morning was a real feat
because they worked in you know the
mental health world and so they but they
saw overtime by chain by slightly
tweaking little behaviors you could
change someone's day you could change
someone's experience of life and this
was really interesting in the human mind
and the in the mental health world but
they also saw that they had a real
passion and a real interest in computers
they would build computers in their
spare time and they saw a lot of
similarities between shaping human
behavior through therapy and mental
health and shaping human behavior
through design development programming
if you create a program that streamlines
someone's taxes or streamline someone's
habit formation or streamline someone's
ability to journal whatever the thing
might be you can ease you can help them
make better choices and make better
decisions in their life and so that was
the sort of switch that they made you
know one thing that they might want to
look at in the future is all these
different mental health apps all these
different meditation apps all these
mindfulness apps that are coming out
how can they get into that field because
they have this background in therapy
tied in with their programming work to
help improve people's mental health at
scale so these are the kinds of things
that you can start thinking about of
what from my past relates to what I'm
currently doing and what I wish to do in
the future and I'm sure you'll be able
to find at least one thing that ties all
the experiences together because it's
all you and you are a cohesive person so
you're you're you're a single entity
trying to accomplish all these things so
it's all coming from the same brain
there's usually a line that you can find
that connect cell all right our next
question all right Pedro what if you
don't have an experience to talk about
in order to back up the answer to your
behavioral interview question I'm
currently in SWE for example to answer
the question tell me about a time that
you had to motivate a team how do I have
anacs--
an experience but what if I didn't and
someone asked me that question I love
this question Pedro hmm this one has
there's this simple answer which I'm
going to jump into and then there's one
that's more complex which like there may
come a time let's let's start with the
complex one there may come a time in an
interview where they ask you about
something that you've never done and our
instinct is going to be to freak out
we're here to be like I don't have
experience in that I'm never gonna get
the job right we can calm ourselves down
because not everyone has every
experience but there are ways to answer
questions that are comforting and there
are ways to answer questions that are
deflating so I've had people that I've
worked with who when they are confronted
with like hey have you ever worked with
this software their answer is no well
how are you going to pick up steam in
that conversation after giving that kind
of an answer
it's going to be pretty hard well you
need to do is say I haven't worked with
that yet
keyword yet because everything is an
evolution of what you're doing today
into the future and you could say I
appreciate you bringing that to my
attention because I'm looking for new
things to learn and add to my list what
I have learned are these programs and
here's how I've learned these programs
and I'll take that same learning
approach to learning this this new thing
that has been brought to my attention
and you can even ask them like how often
do you use it and what do you use it for
and and what do people typically
struggle with when they're trying to
learn that programming language now
you're having a conversation about how
to learn that thing how to gain
experience in that thing rather than
just not rather than just saying I don't
have experience so when it comes to
something like oh I lost the question
here sorry tell me about a time you had
to motivate a team well if you've never
been on a bin like the head of a team
have you motivated a team from inside or
have you been on a sports team and been
a motivator have you done volunteer work
and had to motivate people have you
motivated people in your own personal
life in other ways maybe you have a
bunch of siblings and you had to like
get everyone together to go on a trip
and like decide where to go there's a
lot of different things that you could
potentially talk about that include that
idea of motivation maybe you organized
the maybe you organized the fantasy
football league at your office or
something along those lines
you know I could use the example of in
my first job I had to organize a 5k that
we ran as an office and develop the
t-shirts and get everyone on board and
things like that so there's a number of
different ways that you can answer that
question I would say open your mind a
little bit beyond this the narrow view
set of this job title and thinking
everything has to be perfectly related
and say I can motivate people I likely
have motivated people what are some
examples
from my life that I can draw from a good
example this is in my personal life I
had a little networking group that I ran
now that's not technically work like I'm
not getting paid for it back in the day
years ago but the examples that I can
pull from that are quite strong quite
good examples of getting people together
trying to promote an event trying to
collect emails and share things out and
all that stuff organizing the discussion
those are all different things that are
not technically my job but something
that I have done on mice in my spare
time so for you what would that be again
it could be fantasy football it could be
any number of things maybe you run a
flag football team knows so yeah those
are a few ideas maybe you're a big party
planner and your group of friends that's
it that's a good question when you look
at your group of friends what role are
you are you the party planner are you
like the organizer or you be the person
who's just like brings life in
conversation into the group I know that
there's these like escape rooms that
exist and sometimes the escaper and
depending on the company you're working
with will watch everyone in the room is
there trying to you know unlock all the
locks and everything and give a little
like personality types to everyone like
you're the you're the connector you're
the organizer you're the blah blah blah
and so there's little fun things and
maybe go to WWE ala T's calm to take a
quick personality test and just sort of
get an idea of where your skills lie
where your best and where you maybe have
strengths and weaknesses and things like
that
[Music]
all right Lonnie
I've got your question here what exactly
should we ask these hiring managers
wouldn't some questions seem
unprofessional ie jumping the gun hmm
I'm curious to know Lonnie what
questions you think are jumping a gun
maybe it was something I said earlier or
maybe it's something that you've got in
your head please share them in the in
the chat maybe we can add a little more
context to this so I can make sure I
answer it fully but what exactly should
we ask hiring managers there's two two
parts this question the first part is I
think that when you're talking to a
hiring manager and you're answering
their questions this is in an interview
setting it's really good to get to a
point it's really good to get to a point
where you're having a conversation
rather than doing question answer stop
question answer stop question answer
stop there's actually an example of this
I was years ago talking with my little
brother and he was you know trying to
chat with people on the dating app and
he's like the conversation doesn't seem
to be going anywhere and I looked at the
conversation and it's like what's your
favorite color stop blue nothing what's
your favorite food pizza nothing and
like the cop the topic just kept
changing so there is no flow to the
conversation and so when you're in an
interview it's kind of a weird analogy
but when you're in an interview try and
make try and build some rapport and you
might have to practice this with friends
and and networking connections prior to
getting through the interview but one
thing you can do is say like if they say
what are some of your strengths and
weaknesses like let's say they ask you
what is your weakness your biggest
weakness you give your answer and then
at the end of your answer you say you
know how have you seen others handle
this same weakness within the company
are there learning systems put into
place are there manager check-ins are
there peer reviews like what are some of
the things that you've seen
internally that helped people deal with
this type of skill set and you might
learn that they have you know a very
complex review system put into place to
help people grow and overcome challenges
and things like that so when you're
asking questions you should make it more
about you know learning about the
company learning about the culture the
position and when you get to the end of
the interview I would recommend going to
the Meuse comm or any of these websites
that are career focused and just looking
up good questions to ask during an
informational in or during an interview
during a behavioral interview because
some of the things that you can ask is
you know what skill do you think someone
who would succeed in this role like what
would be the core skill that someone who
would be a success in this role would
have or you could ask the previous
person who had this role what do you
think made them successful what do you
think they could have worked on these
are the types of things things that
reflect back to you stuff you need to
know about that position and also if you
say you know tell me something that
would make someone successful for this
role and they say oh someone who's
extremely organized you can then launch
into oh there's that's awesome because
I've been developing my organization
skills over the last six months and you
know using these apps do you guys use
any of these apps and now you'd have a
conversation going oh yeah we use slack
we use Monday we use whatever the thing
might be to organize conversations oh
that's really cool I have experience
with those programs and then you'd be
like you know we ate we have a little
gift page and blah blah blah and you can
make it a little more personal you know
so these are the kinds of things that I
would say you want to ask questions that
are trying to get their opinions rather
than just saying like how many people
work at the company you can look that up
online or you know what is the salary
you know it's probably a good question
but it's also more of a discussion
rather than a solid answer I would start
by asking more opinion based questions
like where do you think the industry is
going in the next five years what about
your role do you feel contributes like
what about your role do you feel
is like the biggest contribution you're
having to the company like where do you
feel most successful in the work that
you do make them feel good about
themselves make them think about yeah we
are we're like really doing some good
stuff I'm excited to have you on the
team to continue building these things
so those are the kinds of things that
you want to think about when you're
trying to do that
hmm okay Nathaniel part two of your
question the company that I'm applied to
has five teams with a certain role open
how do I figure out who to send a
follow-up email to one week after
applying when I haven't heard a response
yet it's a great question it's great
that you're thinking about following up
and trying to stay on top of things I
would say going back to our previous
discussion reach out to people who have
the same job title that you just applied
to if you talk to one person who has the
same job title that you just applied to
you can ask them do you know who the
hiring manager is and would you be open
to me reaching out to them or if you
don't feel like if you feel like that's
too intrusive if you could say is there
anyone else at the company you'd
recommend that I talk to and they'll
pass you along most likely to someone
closer to the hiring manager or the
hiring manager themselves so I would say
that's probably the way in that's
probably salespeople do it too they
reach out to random person at the
company to try and get any sort of
conversation going within the walls then
they ask that person who else would be
good to talk to and that person bounces
them around and maybe you've talked to
three or four people before you get to
the right person but that's probably the
best strategy so reach out to ten people
who work there five people who work
there whatever you're most comfortable
with get one conversation out of the
five or ten and then use that to sort of
pin ball around until you can find the
right person I would say that's probably
the best approach if you want to go that
hard towards that role but I also think
you should you know allow a little bit
of well no I think that's a good way to
start let's just start with that is it
okay to walk in the interview with my
laptop to show my personal project slash
accomplishments or when managers take it
as hijacking the interview hmm
this is eeeh gum emini I'm sorry I'm
terrible at pronouncing names please
correct me in the chat but is it okay to
walk in the interview with my laptop and
Shawn I think it depends on how you do
it one thing that's good is to have all
the resources you may need to reference
with you when you get to the interview
so if you have a little briefcase or bag
or something like that
just have it ready to go maybe an iPad
who knows what it is I know in the
creative field having a portfolio was
very important people would walk in with
these big you know portfolios and put
them down on the table and walk through
their work and I know you know back when
I was applying for my first job back in
2010 that was starting to shift to
online so people were coming in with
their laptops and then that switch to
iPads and maybe even your phone if you
you don't want to carry all that stuff
around I think it's good to have I
haven't really heard that heard about
situations like that coming up very
often so my question is have you run
into a situation in an interview where
you wish you had your laptop and if that
is the case then start bringing it to
interviews if you haven't had that
experience yet and this is more of an
assumption what I would say you
definitely don't want to do is you don't
want to walk in and the first thing you
do is plop a laptop down on the table
and start walking through stuff you want
to have a good rapport going you want to
start the conversation start the
behavioral interview get into the the
meat of it and then if it comes up in
conversation or if you want to push in
that direction say and they're like hey
can you show can you show me a time that
you've used a certain type of
programming language you could say yeah
absolutely there was this you know
project I was working on it was about
sorting movie titles or something like
that I actually could pull it up if
you'd like to take a look at it and we
can look at it together and then they
have the option to say yes or no and
that way you're not intruding you're
offering more
on text so I would say it depends more
about how you bring it up then having
the laptop in your bag don't come
running in the room with the laptop
already open and forego all pleasantries
so that would be that would be my best
answer to that if you have more context
of course please put it in the chat and
we can try and add a little bit more
alright Hege thank you for your
questions are there any new features on
LinkedIn that are useful but currently
underutilized by people absolutely I'm
gonna pull up LinkedIn real quick so I
can take a look here are some of the
things the first thing I'm lincoln that
is most underutilized by people is the
articles and posting features so a while
back linkedin purchased pulse I believe
it was called pulse and they integrated
it into their website so you can write
articles similar to medium where you you
know it's long-form you could put videos
in it and those articles stay at the
forefront of your profile and give you a
lot of SEO and clout and different
things like that so it's very good if
you're creating content on medium or a
blog or elsewhere to also post it on
LinkedIn it never hurts to add it there
number two posting on LinkedIn and
sharing posts and videos and things like
that in the past ten days and maybe some
of you have been seeing this I've been
blowing up your feed my goal has been to
post at least one excuse me my goal has
been to post at least one unique post
every day and last I looked at my
numbers I think I shot up 300% in
profile views in the past ten days
that's pretty crazy that's that's pretty
crazy for you know just a little bit of
content each day so if you're not
utilizing the
posting feature pictures audio or sorry
pictures video and just writing and
sharing images and stuff like that
you're going to not show up you're not
going to be top of mind with people so I
would recommend doing that if not every
day although that's definitely the best
way to go at least on a on a weekly
basis while you're job searching so that
people remember that you exist you don't
want to just disappear into the ether
let's say so those are - posting
features that allow you to get
visibility another thing you can do is
just comment on other people's stuff
because that shows up in your activity
to like comment interact with what's
happening on LinkedIn it keeps you top
of mind other things that you want to
make sure you have is a complete profile
contact information the skills section
is very important for SEO so if you can
fill that out with all the skills that
you know companies are looking for when
people are looking for to it to hire
they're typing in keywords if those
keywords aren't on your profile you're
not gonna be found so make sure you're
adding those keywords to your profile
LinkedIn learning I think is a really
cool thing I'm not sure how much
additional I don't know boost you get
from LinkedIn learning but if you're
just looking to learn not a bad place to
go and then the final thing I want to
mention is underneath the search bar
when you click on it almost all of us
start in the jobs searching for jobs we
drop we type in the job title and we go
straight to the job listings there are
two other ways to search LinkedIn the
first one is people the second one is
jobs sorry there's three ways to search
LinkedIn the first one is people the
second one is jobs and the third one is
content now the content one I've not did
I've not gone too deep into but I'm
going to be in the next year because I
have a feeling it's going to be a you
know treasure trove of information and
unique interesting ideas the jobs one is
the one that we all know and the people
one I've created a number of videos so
far if you go to youtube and you look up
the reverse job search on my page it'll
walk through
to do a people search and find
networking connections so I really think
the people one is probably the thing I
use the most jobs the second content
third all the contents moving up and
yeah try and utilize the search features
more and I did read an article recently
the last thing I'll say is hashtags a
lot of people are using hashtags to
research companies so if you're really
interested in artificial intelligence
follow the artificial intelligence
hashtag and you might find lots of
smaller businesses that wouldn't
normally pop up in your search results
who have less competition for jobs so
definitely give that a give that a whirl
give that a shot
[Music]
thoughts about Reid aren't Hudson thank
you for your question
thoughts about reaching out to companies
without relevant current job openings
for example I have a list of companies
I'm interested in should I send an
introductory letter explaining why I
like the company and a hypothetical role
where I can add value
awesome question Hudson and this is
gonna be one where we revisit some of
the things that we've been saying
throughout the call it's not about you
at the end of the day so a hundred
percent if you have a list of companies
that you want to be reaching out to you
should be reaching out to them but you
shouldn't be reaching out to the company
generally you should be reaching out to
individuals which is what you'd have to
do anyway but you're not gonna send it
to hello at company comm you're gonna be
reaching out to individuals who work at
that company and rather than saying
here's who I am and here's what I like
about the company and here's the role
that I want to do you can say what is it
you know while I was doing research on
your company because I find it to be a
really interesting industry a really
interesting company doing interesting
things your name came up it looks like
you're working on some really cool stuff
I'd love to learn more about it then
when you're in the conversation with
that person you can say what are you
struggling with what are you excited
about and they might say oh I'm really
struggling with this that or this or
this or I'm really excited to launch
this new project and you can say well if
you're struggling with those things I
have a few hours I could work part-time
or contract and just help you out with
that project that new project launch or
or that thing that's really causing you
a lot of pain now you're providing value
within context of their needs rather
than asking for something within the
context of your own needs so I hope that
helps you with how to reach out but I
love your question I definitely think
you should be reaching out even if jobs
aren't listed because what that does is
it gets you in so that when a job does
get listed you're the first one getting
referred to it I hope that's helpful
all right leggo I'm a mean sorry again
I'm terrible at names is it okay to
dress more casual for software
development interview is it okay to
development interviews nothing too
casual ie bazinga t-shirts but is it
okay to show up not wearing a dress
shirt and tie this is a fantastic
question because things have changed so
much in the last decade when I graduated
college you had to wear a suit the
startup scene hadn't really caught on as
much I'm sure there were some companies
that were fine with t-shirts but it was
all suits all day and now I actually a
few years back I think maybe three years
back I applied for a job and I was flown
out to Boston to interview and all I
brought was like you know the clothes on
my back and my little padfolio excels
only going out in the morning coming
back that night and I wore a suit so all
I had with me was a suit I didn't have
any other clothes I didn't have anything
I was just a suit for the day and I
showed up and I get to the office and
it's a start-up it's a boot camp it's
it's this little this little company and
they are like what are you doing wearing
a suit and everyone's just in jeans and
t-shirts what I'm wearing basically
right now and I'm like you know I just
wanted to make good impression something
along those lines and they go ah that's
funny and they were all super nice about
it but they're giving me little jabs
they were like you know you don't have
to wear a suit take that tie off and
stuff and I told this story I was like
well you know whenever I go to a wedding
my brothers and I have a pact that as
long as there's a camera around we are
going to stay suited up ties fully
suited up ties done fully suited up and
so I made that joke and we kind of
laughed about it like you know you're at
a wedding like everyone else is in you
know their undershirts and like sweaty
and we're all just like perfectly trim
and that was a funny little joke and
then
throughout the day they kept saying come
on undo that tie undo that time it's
like no and I would always make it a
little tighter every time they said it
and it was just it was a fun little
dynamic
so again if like you mess up as I quote
unquote messed up wearing the wrong
clothes you can still make it
interesting make it fun make it a story
and I end up getting that job so it was
really good but what I find funny about
the whole like how to dress for things
is that it's very so much and this is
why you need to talk to people at the
company this is why you need to network
before you go in for an interview so you
can say like how do people typically
dress here and I would say the rule of
thumb is dress slightly better than what
their baseline company dress code is so
if it's you know t-shirt and hoodie show
up in a button-down if it's button-down
show up in a blazer if it's blazer show
up in a suit you know just take it a
step higher than whatever they're doing
in the company take it a step higher
than whatever they're doing in the
company all right we got about five
minutes left I try and grab a couple
more questions here
are there difference I tryin
orion's question are there different
strategies for the job search depending
on my personal timeline especially for
shorter one to two month search
timelines especially for shorter one to
two months search timelines so I assume
what you're saying with this question is
that you need a job in the next one to
two months rather than saying I want a
job that's one to two months long okay
so if you need a job in the next one to
two months is it different I think it's
just more intense like you need to be on
it every day like all day as much as
possible depending on your situation
like do you have a job right now are you
gonna run out of money what what is the
situation that's putting you on a one to
two month timeline there are certain
things I wouldn't do if you're on that
one to two months timeline so you know
I've given recommendations in the past
of go start a podcast in order to
network that's a long term you know
creative strategic way to build your
career but it's not exactly the fastest
way to get to the next job that you want
to get to I don't think you can really
avoid networking setting up one-on-one
coffees I think no matter where you are
in your job search you have to be doing
that it's just are you doing four
coffees a day or a couple a week right
there was a point where I was pretty
desperate for a job I was about five
months into a job search I don't know in
2013 or something like that and I was
getting pretty desperate I was going on
three four coffees a day as many times
as I could I had nothing else going on
so the fact that I wasn't going on
coffees for the you know five months
prior was a was a big mistake on my part
so what you needed to do what I needed
to do was really increase the number of
people I was talking with I needed to
increase my my like strategic approach
to those conversations to make it more
about like hey can I get a referral
you know at the end of the day what
other things I mean getting a job in one
to two months you're gonna have to go
into sales mode you're gonna have to
start really getting specific about the
companies you want to work for and and
the solutions that you're bringing them
so probably the best thing to do if you
really need a job in the next one to two
months is target startups and reach out
to the founders because they're not
gonna be they're gonna be easier to
reach than hiring managers at you know a
fortune 400 company so what you need to
do is say like okay I can do whatever
I'm gonna do whatever I can to get a job
of this company we have an example of an
old student who she was a programmer but
she just wanted to work this company so
bad that she emailed them and said I'll
do anything you need and I can start for
free she's like I'll do an internship
and I'm paid an internship for a month
if you let me come on and I'll just do
anything you need and she eventually
worked that unpaid internship into a
full-time program sorry she worked that
unpaid internship into a full-time
programming job it just took a few
months but she needed to get the
experience and get working and get a
foot in the door first so there are
different things that you can do to
really speed things up but I would
actually recommend doing those things
regardless of your timeline because your
goal here is to help people the more
people you help the closer you'll get to
being able to get paid to help people
and I think that's really the approach
than the mindset that we need to have in
our head at the end of the day all right
we've come to the end of the hour I'm
sorry we didn't get to every single
question but thank you so much for
sharing your thoughts and sharing your
questions throughout today's ask a
career coach I'm really excited to jump
into next week and do this again with
you all I'll be cutting up this video in
these questions and sharing them on my
profile throughout the week as well so
if you want to follow along there but
definitely check out Udacity z-- career
resources go to the website and just
at our careers page and fill out the
survey that Rui will be putting in the
chat to let us know how we can improve
these in the future and if you have more
questions you can reach out to us
anytime on slack LinkedIn or any of the
other channels that you know we're at so
thank you so much for joining us please
RSVP for next week and I look forward to
helping you and helping answer all of
your career questions in the future
Cheers
[Music]